hey david why don't republicans
focus on policy instead of culture war
issues wouldn't it be better for them
electorally
i don't know that it would be and the
reason that i say that
is it's not clear to me that republicans
actually have the support to win
on the issues if repub what what was it
that donald trump did
that prior republicans didn't do that
essentially
gave trump the victory in 2016. it was
that he ran a campaign
based on cultural issues and
personal attacks and fears
about communism socialism hillary etc
where his voters didn't actually have to
evaluate policy and say does the policy
actually
sound good to me some examples where the
republican party if they were to run on
policy would have
a problem abortion is still used to
raise a lot of money by republican
candidates but the truth is that the
american public is more in favor of
abortion being legal in most cases
than it has at any time in the roe v
wade era so
if republicans really made abortion a
bigger issue
it might not be so good for them uh if
you look at
the republican perspective on taxation
when you really get down to it i've said
a lot of bad things about
the populist movement and how they can
bamboozle people
but one of the things that the more
populist republican base
has gone towards is to be more hostile
to tax plans that are just good for rich
people now trump still passed one that
is mostly that
but because policy was so secondary and
the cultural issues were more important
trump was able to achieve an electorate
that really doesn't care very much what
his policy is
most of the things he promised he was
never going to be able to do and it
didn't even matter no one actually held
him accountable
and ultimately what brought trump down
was his mishandling of the coveted
pandemic i maintained that if the
coveted pandemic
hadn't happened and because trump
mishandled it
right there's the idea well trump could
have handled it well and won yeah trump
was not going to handle it well
if trump didn't end up having to
mishandle kovid
he almost certainly would have been
reelected and to me
when you say why doesn't the republican
party run on policy
it seems to me it's actually better for
them electorally to run on these
cultural issues we're against critical
race theory
nobody can even define it these people
barely know what it is
but it gets so much oxygen think about
the coverage of critical race theory on
fox news over the last three to four
months
and then think of how it fires up the
base and it spreads i mean
these memes spread like wildfire money
is raised
i'm coming out in opposition of critical
race theory in schools donate to me
imagine if the entire time it had been
about like tax policy
they would not have gotten the attention
that they did and so to me
it actually seems you know same thing
with we're against communism and
socialism
joe biden's making us a communist nation
you ask these people what is communism
they have no idea
and this allows them to continue moving
forward without ever really having to be
accountable for bad policy
by just not talking about policy i
actually am
increasingly of the mindset that
republicans do better right now
by talking about the cultural issues
than they do
uh by actually switching over to policy
check out my segment from earlier this
week
whether a culture war is even winnable
because that's another factor that the
left has to consider but
i don't think that i think it's
disgusting
in terms of the debasement of american
political discussion
that there's one party that doesn't even
pretend to care about policy that's
really bad for the country
but i think it's probably in a sense the
better choice
for the republican party in terms of
winning elections because they have
a constituency that wants to just fight
and yell and scream and cheer about
cultural issues
and they don't really want to deal with
policy in any serious way that's why
trump won in 2016
were it not for covid he would have won
in 2020 as well
send me your thoughts if you disagree
with me i do want to hear from you
we have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at
joinpackman.com get instant access and
we will see you then